people want to feel great before they
start anything the confidence part will
come over time confidence needs evidence
if that's how you feed it
take some pressure off yourself and just
get started
changing your mindset can make such an
impact
so I'm doing this to raise the bar and
what women think is possible
[Music]
the big challenge of it is just knowing
that you're going to suffer and seeing
how you're going to do in the suffering
hey everybody happy holidays and so much
love from me and my team here at the
studio
as this year comes to a close comes to a
conclusion I thought it would be
beautiful appropriate and cool to take a
little bit of time to appreciate the
unbelievable library of conversations
that we've recorded over the last 12
months on everything from spirituality
to Health Fitness psychology aging and
even magic and so to celebrate all of
these amazing episodes we here today are
going to indulge in an annual tradition
that we conduct on this podcast ending
each year with a two-part compilation on
the finest excerpts from the previous 12
months of the show starting with the
good Dr Andrew huberman
your actions do in some sense Define you
both to other to people outside of you
and and to oneself uh there's this
concept in uh psychoanalysis of the
introject which I find fascinating the
interject is this idea that we can
subconsciously embody the reactions of
somebody else so um you know one thing
that fascinates me now that I'm a bit
more involved in you know sort of online
interactions and social medias you know
the tremendous number of really
inspiring people out there I put you in
this category I'll put you on the spot
and embarrass you but I read your book
long before we met and was really
motivated to make a number of important
changes in my life on the basis of of
reading that book it truly was and it so
just to you know embarrass you a bit
here but that's that's the reality I'm
gonna get flush
appropriately yeah because uh it was an
it's an incredible journey and or um you
know last time we talked about David
Goggins and there are many examples
right you can go online now and see
examples of incredible people doing
incredible things now one version of
that is to think oh that's inspiring it
change it shifts my autonomic arousal so
I can get up at 4 30 in the morning like
Jocko and like get after it and do this
stuff which and frankly there have been
times when I'll see a social media post
so I'm like yeah you know I'm being lazy
I should really push a little harder I'm
or you had Chad Wright on here right it
was content you know he and I um are
very different in a variety of ways and
we've never met but I find his content
in incredibly inspiring because the the
way that he communicates his conviction
even though some of my convictions are
different than his and so
um and I learned about him through
through you so we could consider that
inspiration but then the idea of the
analyst that I think is appropriate and
keep in mind that that while Freud there
were many issues with him and Jung and
Analysis they did have a heavy
um interest in physiology as the root of
the subconscious and there's this idea
of the introject is fascinating to me
because what it says is that if you
consume enough of that content if you
read enough books about people who have
embarked on certain kinds of Journeys
and made certain choices that at some
point you might interject some of their
personality and their responses and
subconsciously start making decisions
hopefully positive decisions on your own
behalf maybe having more appropriate
boundaries maybe taking better self-care
or care of other people and that without
even realizing it you're starting to
make better choices on your own behalf
and then at some point you move from the
interject to a recognition that wait it
was me that made that change I'm the one
that man should get up a bit earlier and
do a little bit more to be kinder in
this context or to listen a little bit
better in this context and over time we
start to ascribe those changes to
ourselves so this is a more gradual
shift in personality and the story of of
who one is but I think it's a powerful
one and I like it because you know we
hear so much today about the negativity
that's out there and how to navigate the
the just onslaught of negative news and
negative interactions online and for
that reason I really make an effort to
really focus on the kind of the bright
shining uh lights out there because I do
think that the information that we
consume sets the car the internal
context of our subconscious and sets the
internal context for what we decide to
do consciously and in many ways it's
sort of like garbage in garbage out and
if it's you know positive stories and
inspiration in that's how you're
basically going to react in the world so
I I think that the nervous system has a
tremendous capacity to learn consciously
and subconsciously and after all it is
during sleep that our nervous system
rewires it you know we know that the
dreaming that occurs during rapid eye
movement sleep has this very unique
signature of being very emotionally
Salient you know falling being chased
Etc but that the body is incapable
of releasing adrenaline epinephrine
during that time so that's its own sort
of form of trauma therapy right so
that's a subconscious learning that we
go through each night provided we're
getting into rapid eye movement sleep so
the brain is is designed to access these
states in sleep that help us rewire in
beneficial ways you can if you want I
don't recommend it you can run the other
experiment sleep deprive yourself for
three nights and see how your
emotionality is doing right yeah that's
super interesting I mean I think
ultimately though it always goes back to
action like you can consume a tremendous
amount of inspirational content and then
convince yourself that you did something
productive or you feel better about
yourself without having ever actually
done anything and I you know I see a lot
of that as well but ultimately at some
point you would think that that's going
to translate into some kind of action or
behavior one would hope and and that
brings up kind of these ideas around
Alter Ego right like if you feel
yourself not worthy of you know being
that type of person you see Jocko he's
waking up at 4 30 in the morning and
doing what he does does and you say well
what would Jaco do and then you do that
like you kind of Step into the alter ego
of Jocko and what he would do and start
mimicking that behavior over time then
like you said you wake up and you
realize like oh it's me I no longer I
Can Shed that Alter Ego now and I can
kind of own this space for myself yeah
exactly and and I think that
um you know one of the hardest things to
do is to calibrate one's consumption of
social media or or any kind of a high
potency information I mean if you think
about it this is the first time in human
history that you can scroll through 50
movies in one minute right right I mean
you know if a picture is worth a
thousand words right you know that a
movie is worth 10 000 pictures I mean
the the visual system loves motion and
so there's you know I'm sure the
algorithms reflect this and so really
setting constraints on the amount of
interaction with stuff is important and
I think setting constraints on what type
of information you're going to consume I
mean there is something about our
nervous system that draws us to look at
the car crash you know to
um you know click behind that uh muted
screen that's that allows you to see the
Gory thing or to
um get involved in some sort of a very
narrow context online argument I mean
everyone is prone to that some people
more than others but you know there's
also a lot of incredible content out
there and I think that
the high potency positive content
whatever that means you know for some
people that's listening to a piece of
classical music these days I'm really
interested in and finding a lot of
incredible artwork on online and just
going wow like people are creating some
amazing stuff
you know that can be inspiring so it
comes in a variety of different forms
for different people but being very I
think that we all need to be more
guarded of the kinds of information and
the context that we expose our nervous
systems to and the problem with social
media to just acknowledge it is that
it's a free-for-all in terms of context
and you can set limits on it in time but
you can't set limits on it in in terms
of context at all unless you're very
good at self-governing confidence isn't
the start of something it's the result
of something so how do you Foster it
what behaviors and thought processes
cultivate conviction and what does it
take to beat imposter syndrome I'm
asking for a friend best-selling author
of radical confidence and co-founder of
Quest Nutrition Lisa bilyeu dropped by
the Pod to answer these questions and
more here's a powerful clip from that
conversation
confidence to me was like how you feel
about yourself so people want to feel
great before they start anything I was
the same I was like oh I'm gonna start
my YouTube Channel Once I have the
confidence and so what hence ends up
happening is people don't actually take
action because they're waiting for the
confidence to come and I joke about it
in the book but it's like you know like
if you wanted glutes to steal you won't
go to the gym do a couple of reps and
think that you're all done right it's
kind of like with confidence it's like
you have to keep practicing it takes
some action exactly and so the very
first part that I say is okay identify
what you want confidence in
to do what with the confidence because
we're all focusing on feeling good but
actually what do you want to achieve
usually people will say I want
confidence to tell my boss that I want
to pay wise I want the confidence to
tell my partner in my relationship I'm
not happy I want the confidence to tell
my parents I no longer want to study
biochemistry and I want to be a stand-up
comedian
so it's usually something to to do
something with and I'm like great now
you know the end goal now you've
identified the end goal now you need to
come up with a set of tools Stepping
Stones to get to that goal because the
confidence part will come over time it
will come with action it will come with
repetition it will come with gaining
competence the confidence is the
byproduct and so if we can stop focusing
on the confidence and have radical
confidence which to me means you have
insecurities you have doubts in yourself
you actually probably are not equipped
for what you're about to do
but you still show up and do it anyway
now I don't mean blindly believing in
yourself I don't mean blindly saying I
forget the fear and do it anyway no no
when you've got the fear you need to me
I needed stepping stones that were
binary
okay I wake up today did I do this yes
or no so some people for instance let's
take the gym working out fitness
I know my mom didn't have the confidence
to even walk in the gym
okay she wanted to lose weight she
wanted to be healthy but she didn't have
the confidence she didn't believe in
herself she didn't think she was worthy
enough so now you have someone that in
her 70s still says losing weight wasn't
possible
because she was waiting for the
confidence to then feel good about
herself to go in the gym and it became
this like you know vicious cycle yeah so
instead of just saying okay we'll just
go to the gym gym fill the phone do it
anyway come up with the steps stepping
process so you want confidence to feel
good about yourself to go to the gym
okay the end goal is the gym now what do
you do make it binary tomorrow I put my
shoes by my bed
that's it did you do it yes or no and
now you create this plan this action
plan
around the thing that you're trying to
do so that every day you don't allow
your negative mindset the voice in your
head that's saying you're not worthy
you're not good enough you don't let it
take over you don't want it to go in
onto autopilot and that's what I was
doing for eight years my entire life was
autopilot because every time I wanted to
do something that mindset was coming in
saying well you don't have the
confidence you're not good enough who Do
You Think You Are
and a quest because I we were growing so
quickly we grew at 57 000 and so I
didn't have the luxury to a slow down I
didn't have the luxury because our house
was on the line I didn't have the life
she'd just stop and say I don't know how
and I don't have the confidence to do
that so when I found myself walking into
a boardroom
where let's say there's 10 guys with
business way more business experience
than me the insecurity comes flooding
right that I don't have the confidence
to walk into the room the Imposter
syndrome comes one you know
um front and center now the question is
how on Earth do you still walk in the
room what do you do how do you know that
actually you know what I don't have as
much experience than everyone in the
room it's not even like I'm just like
putting myself down I actually don't
have the experience that everyone else
does in this room so how on Earth do I
keep showing up if I don't have the
confidence that's what radical
confidence is
and so what are those tools like I'm
imagining walking into that boardroom
feeling insecure you have a couple
choices you can act as if and put on a
front and pretend that you're on their
level which is very transparent or
there's the opportunity to acknowledge
to yourself like hey I'm like
maybe not at this level yet I still have
to walk into this room like how do I
manage that and you can come in and say
listen this is who I am I'm not like I
don't have your experience but I'm here
that requires a level of self-esteem as
well to be able to say that to admit
that weakness and part of your you know
your kind of process here is about like
acknowledging your own weaknesses rather
than repressing them or pretending they
don't exist it's like bring them to the
surface be in relationship with them so
you understand what they are which gives
you an opportunity to then work on them
and kind of get to the other side yeah
exactly and to your point there's no way
I would have had the guts to tell people
I'm not your level yet like that you
know the instinct is just pretend like
go in pretend that you know what you're
doing it's like but that's just too
crippling sometimes and so I actually
took this from my husband have the
identity of the learner
so now if you've got the identity of the
learner instead of being the identity
that I know what I'm doing I've got this
I'm the head of shipping you know I'm
Tom's wife I'm the co-founder that
didn't help just because I was the
co-founder of company didn't mean that I
actually knew what I was doing or was
confident to walk into a boardroom so if
you adopt the identity of the learner
now when you walk into a boardroom how
do you think I feel I'm like oh I'm
gonna land in this room when I go into a
situation where someone's saying
something that I don't know I was like
oh wait please explain because I don't
understand that but now as a learner I
thrive off learning now if I fall to my
knees and I make a mistake or a
catastrophic mistake as the learner I
don't take that as a dent to my ego I
just say oh my God great now I can learn
from this failure
next up is star of screens big and small
Terry Crews who join me on episode 676
for a long form exchange on overcoming
toxic masculinity
transcending obstacles confronting your
past and stepping into your truest power
and most actualized self
I am an idealist
um and I think it comes with being an
artist or just seeing a vision and just
seeing a better way and going oh I want
to go I want that you know
[Music]
um
and the thing is is that for me
what was wild is that I always thought
things were impossible or I thought it
was magic you know
but what I began to do is in order to be
the person I wanted to be
I had to say like I have it already like
I had to to in order to be to have the
money and be a let's say consider
yourself a rich person
you have to look at the riches you have
and say
I have this you know into order to have
you must do and then once you say I have
this you do the things a rich person
would do
and all of a sudden you are
but but remember that when in my mom's
religion the due part was gone
it was gone
and I realized that in the action
first of all the visualization and then
the action
And Then There It Is it comes
and it's almost it's almost like I said
you're you're in
you don't know you're in Los Angeles but
you are you know you're you're
so nobody somebody just close your eyes
blindfolded you plopped you right there
in it
you all of a sudden
would have to know like you know you
would have markers and different things
and all this all this stuff but the
realization is that you are there
and you have to be there now and then
you behave like you're there now right
dude it's a deep thought yeah yeah you
own that truth it just hasn't happened
yet like my friend Jesse hitzler has a
he has a quote that he used to a mantra
that he would repeat to himself when he
was a young person like I'm a
millionaire they just haven't paid me
yet but like you know that idea applying
to everything like I you know you just
you you Intuit or you inhabit the idea
of what that
who that person is who has the thing
that you want or is living the life that
you want and you then conduct yourself
accordingly let me tell you another
perfect example is the first time I've
tried to quit pouring
you're like this is the hardest thing
ever like what am I going to do with my
I remind you I had three different jobs
I started working like crazy because I
was like what am I doing my time you
know yeah and but I was it was hard
because I was like this was what I used
to do
and when I didn't do it anymore the
habit for doing something had you you
don't you don't get rid of things you
just replace them
and I started to replace it with good
things and all of a sudden
I didn't have any desire for it anymore
but I can't Mark the moment
I can't Mark the time it was 12 years
but then all of a sudden you go I don't
need that that's not me anymore I'm a
whole nother person
and it's so incredible it's almost like
going back through those Franklin
planners
and realizing wait you saw yourself
there you you're even past that
you know what I mean yeah but it's also
the difference between white knuckling
it like I'm gonna apply my self-will to
this problem and and just like I am not
going to do this thing versus like I'm
letting go I'm transcending this because
I am becoming this other person who
wouldn't do that let me tell you and
that that is a great thing because I
have to tell you this because willpower
doesn't work
doesn't work believe me I tried the
first time I was getting out of it and
you're like uh you're like no it it's
ridiculous but what I realized is that
it's not a willpower issue
it's a lack of information issue the
more you start to realize and know it
changes you
I like when you know what it's doing
when you know what it's costing
you know I did things like making logs
of how much I spent on all that every
day
and you think if you didn't write it
down you go I spent 20 bucks it when I
actually wrote it down it was 300 and
you go what in the world but you we
don't we you can't rely on our intuition
that way you have to start to really
write it down see it and the whole thing
and The Willpower does not work it's got
to be the info the info what do what is
it I don't know
and once you start going out like that
you know what you're trying to lose what
you know what to eat you know what
causes you to do these things you know
you know what exercises to do you know
what to be and it's so and it all of a
sudden it changes you you wake up and
you're just different because you know
more and you're responsible for more the
more you know the more you're
responsible for and so it makes it an
amazing I like to call it it moves from
a toilet into a tornado
the spin just starts to go up and up and
up enough you know the toilet is the
other way you know but the tornado it
gets better and better and better
Dr Lisa Miller is a psychologist and
Pioneer in the scientific study of
spirituality on the podcast to promote
her new book The awakened brain Dr
Miller delivered an incredible Deep dive
on the numerous benefits of cultivating
a spiritual practice the ways such a
practice can enhance things like grit
and optimism and even insulate you from
addiction and depression here is a slice
of that fascinating conversation when we
tell a story a memory in a way that's
very palpable and Rich and has lots of
sensory
points real anchors in it that bring us
back in time we elicit the same neural
correlates as if we were there plus
memory and Mark potenzo working with
Regina sin had become one of the leading
experts around addiction and he had
found that the addiction Loop in our
brain the insulin striatum is the same
whether we are addicted to alcohol and
drugs or pornography in the internet or
gambling it's the same I've got to have
it right so they had worked together
Rashid and Mark in the past developing
this in scanner task when it came to
craving when it came to telling stories
of addiction hungry and I need to have
the drug I need to have I I I've got to
get to Vegas I've got to have this you
know roll of the dice well when I
approached them
I said you know we know from
epidemiology that there's nothing as
protective Against Addiction as a strong
personal spirituality can we watch that
in the scanner and of course as
open-minded creative scientist Mark and
Regina were thrilled we sat down for a
year and a half then we took the
following question after a year and a
half of inquiry to 18 through 25 year
olds we said tell us a Time
when you felt a deep connection with
your higher power some people say God
Jesus Allah Hashem some people say the
universe or a Oneness with all life
but tell us a time where you felt a deep
connection
with a deeper deeper presence of life
that was loving and guiding
nobody was confused 18 to 25 year olds
in New Haven a lot of them were Yale
students a lot of them were agnostic
some spiritual but not religious some
not friendly to the whole idea of
religion nobody was surprised everyone
had an important experience
everyone
and how many people what was the
population size well okay so in order to
in you know in MRI studies there's often
very small samples that you can publish
today with like 10. but we had about 30
people who went through every phase of
this study
and in the study whether they were
Christian Catholic Jewish Muslim Hindu
spiritual but not religious
no matter what their background was the
same neural correlates ran as they told
us that narrative
and what is a neuro correlate
so as they as we wanted to be very
precise we literally knew at what point
in their study they felt this unit of
experience so we had them tell their
stories this is part of Vegeta sin's
method over 15 years
tell the story
tell it again well it's audio taped
play it back in earbuds in the MRI
machine while the fmri is running so
that we can pinpoint to the T what
neural correlates are seeing what
happens in the MRI as you say this
specific little passage in your story
and right at the point where the young
adults would say
I'm walking down the street I'm
completely depressed I've just been
turned down at five out of six medical
schools I'm such a loser I'm never going
to be a doctor like my mother
but then suddenly I see light in the
leaves
and I know that God has a plan for me or
suddenly I see light in the leaves and I
know that life is buoyant and I will be
a Healer in the way I am intended or
suddenly I see light in the leaves and I
know that there's a path for me greater
than anything I know yet that aha the
reshuffling of meaning that is
illuminated and speaks to a true part of
myself right is that
part of the narrative is told we saw
coming up online four major components
of what we're calling the awakened brain
the first is that
quieting I'm such a loser quieting the
racket the default mode is powered down
now that you can do through mindfulness
that's simply getting present that's the
network of rumination exactly right
right now very often because we have a
hungry culture many people are taught
mindfulness to get present and it's
helpful but it only stops there it only
gets us present when in fact
what then is potentiated is that we are
at a threshold to cross for being
present into a state of Awakened
awareness it's mindfulness plus it's
Crossing into and the next three Loops
or first and foremost just as we were
held as children and our parents are
grandparents arms we feel loved we feel
held the bonding network is engaged and
we are aware that life itself is holding
the next is the prime that's the fronto
temporal yes yes exactly right so that
was the
um yes that was the article and in fact
that well I'll tell the whole story then
the next piece to come online is the
parietal it puts in and out heart
boundaries so just as there's a sense of
discrete and specific experiences you
have your path you live in California
you have your family you look like you
and I live in Connecticut
we are distinct we are magnificently
diverse we are different and at the same
time there's a deep calming unit of
experience a common human heart
the parietal puts in and out hard
boundaries so that we can toggle between
a sense of difference and common love
common felt being
and then the final piece which is just
to put a put a finer point on that
reduced activity in the parietal lobe
um allows
the influx of this sense of of
commonality among all is that right is
that fair that we are connected right or
one
exactly and then finally this is a
particular importance to Innovation to
decision making the armies really
championed this dimension of Awakened
awareness we move from a narrow top-down
dorsal attention Network
tactical strategical we've got to get
out the red door we've planned we're
prepared everybody's trained we're going
out the red door but today here live
The Red Doors jammed we can't get out
that's a metaphor of course for life you
know everything was in the bag a plus b
plus C of course it was me who was going
to be promoted and then they what they
brought in somebody or a plus b plus C
you know I was the one it was my turn to
be quarterback it was my turn to be on
the varsity football team and what I got
cut you know so it all didn't add up
the red door stuck and because the red
door's stuck we shift in a state of
Awakened awareness from the top down
narrow bowling alley perception of the
dorsal to the bottom-up ventral
attention Network we have a much broader
field of perception far more information
and many people say that the right
answer the new possibility pops the
yellow door
never would have seen the yellow door
but the yellow door leads to a landscape
that was surprising that could be
magnificently
in the big sense of the word prosperous
I meet the person who I am best friends
with the rest of my life I find a line
of work I never dreamed of I end up in a
city that was so very much at home the
yellow door opens and that possibility
of bottom-up perception leads to a form
of creativity and Innovation the Army
calls situational awareness right that
allows us to align with the way life
really is alright people enter Brad
stolberg writer coach and personal
friend specializing in human performance
and well-being Brad made his third
appearance on the podcast this year back
in episode 677 delivering a powerful
primer on the principles upon which to
build sustainable success and a life
grounded in meaning and fulfillment what
about the relationship between presence
and groundedness particularly in the
context of like working with very driven
people presence feels like an Indulgence
it feels like an obstacle in the a way
of achieving whatever you need to get
done on a particular day so you have to
sell the bill of goods as to why this is
important time out you said on a
particular day and that's the thing
deep presence in
um really like honing that is never
going to get you the most work done on a
particular day ever but it might over
the course of a year or a decade or a
career and that's the tortoise over
there and that's how you settle that
score right there I'm super clear with
my coaching clients they've come to me
talking about efficiency and
productivity and optimization and I'm
like all these things are great I want
all these things too but on what time
scale because if I wanted to optimize
over the next 24 hours or even over the
next week let's say I would slam
espresso and red bulls I'd sleep four
hours a night and I would just bury
myself and that'd be super optimal but
not for a month certainly not for a year
so I think that there's the zooming out
and saying hey like what time skill are
we operating on and there the research
is unequivocal if you're talking about
Excellence or success over the Long Haul
being present for the work that actually
matters is perhaps the most important
variable that you can do to set yourself
up for that success right we don't
intuitively think about these Horizons
in decade-long chunks we think about the
next quarterly earnings or you know the
next six months or perhaps the next year
but if you really want to build
sustainability which is what is at the
core of what this is all about like how
do you want to operate to the best of
your ability for the longest period of
time you have to broaden that window
right and I've had to learn this like
I'm you know I just want to grind and
grind and grind and I've been doing this
podcast for almost 10 years it became
pretty clear like two years ago like I I
I'm not going to make it like I have to
figure out a different way of doing this
so that I can maintain my joy for it and
my presence when I'm sitting with guests
and my enthusiasm for you know consuming
all of their wisdom and material and
being able to deliver on the best
experience conversational experience
that I can
I can't sustain it the way I was doing
it so now I take a month off every year
I've hired a team and like I've I've had
to learn how to you know overcome this
perfectionism and control impulses and
those were not easy lessons for me and
I'm not great at them every day either
but it was in this it was like a
necessity I think in order to do that
which gets into we're sort of moving out
of presence and more into the next thing
which is which is patience yeah and I
think built into patients is this idea
of looking at things you know on a
longer time frame yeah real quick I
jotted a note down did you during that
period and we don't have to name Gus but
did you ever find yourself resenting the
fact that you had to come in and talk to
someone
it never got that bad but I was moving
in that direction yeah and I really
never wanted to feel that way yeah and I
realized that if I didn't change some
things that I was quickly going to be
that person yeah and obviously that's at
odds with the experience that I'm trying
to cultivate and create I asked that
because that emotion is often in my
coaching clients
um a game changer for helping people
realize that their work style is too
frenetic and frantic and too quote
unquote optimized on short time scales
is people come to resent work but they
once loved and the only thing that's
changed about the work is that when they
started doing it they were a team of one
and they had a really low bar and they
spent most of their day deep in the
creative work and now suddenly they're
running meetings and their leading teams
and that deep focused present work has
gone away
and they start to resent their job and
the number one thing to help those
people are to help them reclaim those
those moments of presence and I'll say
one more thing on this before moving on
to patients because I think it's it's a
very important coaching insight and that
is that
it unequivocally you will fail if you
just say I want to be more present and
even if you try to work top down you'll
likely fail so to say like I need to be
present all the time it's never going to
work there's too many distractions so
with clients I always have folks work
bottom up so that means just start with
two hours a week so schedule ahead of
time two one hour blocks where you know
what you're going to do during that
period so when it rolls around you don't
just pull up your email
and just start there and then after two
weeks try an hour and a half and I had
this one client
who came to me because of feeling
resentment and just like
coming to hate a job that she loved and
at first I'm like yeah maybe it's the
job actually and she needs to move on
but it quickly became clear that she
actually loved work she just didn't love
how she was running around frantically
and she said there's no way she could be
present she's high up she runs this huge
team she's got kids blah blah blah blah
and we just started with an hour a day
and slowly but surely she proved to
herself that the world wasn't going to
end if for an hour a day she put
everything away and worked and a year
into our coaching relationship this is a
true story I and I try to practice what
I preach so I am very um
I have boundaries around when I coach
it's like certain days certain times and
I went to try to work with her executive
assistant to get a coaching slot and the
person's like no like sorry like Kate
can't meet with you then
blocked off her window and your window
so she went from impossible to be
present at a company with over a
thousand people to
um three and a half to four hours a day
but it started if I would have told her
that at the beginning she would have
fired me and I think the same's true
with ourselves even if you don't have a
coach individually if you tell yourself
oh I'm gonna be present for four hours
and you fail it's like a diet it's like
anything you're off the wagon it's hard
to get back on so I think starting
really small and again it's it's a
common theme in this book and and I
think this is the coach in me is that
you take something that's really Noble
and aspirational but for it to work
you've got to get super concrete and
start at a level that is like in the
weeds
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
we all want to positively change the
world but where do you even start with
such an idea how do you begin well
philanthropist and impact investor
Jacqueline novogratz has dedicated the
better part of her life to answering
this question she's just an incredible
woman who has made an extraordinary
impact on improving the lives of
millions of people across the developing
World she's very much a personal hero of
mine and in episode 657 please check
this one out if you missed it Jacqueline
shares actionable Sustainable Solutions
to some of our world's biggest
challenges there are so many
well-intentioned people in philanthropy
and yet
you know there's just too many stories
of you know funds just and ending up you
know there's all kinds of
um
uh issues around corruption and just
organizations being poorly run and the
money seems to disappear and Nobody ends
up benefiting and it's all like a just a
big [ __ ]
yeah like how does it how does that
happen with people who I'm sure are
trying to do the right thing and help
I often say that distance dulls the
moral imagination
and so we we want to do good we want to
be part of good and so we give money
um hoping it does good but that's not
enough we've actually got to build in
systems that
have like to your to your word of
accountability generosity without
accountability
um can really make a mess of things and
and and it's not the same as justice
justice is hard
generosity can be hard but it's a lot
easier than Justice and so
um
when there's no accountability in
systems and if you think about an aid
system where people are coming and going
they're not vested
it becomes even easy or for many of the
different flares
to take different pieces of whatever is
available so it's gotten a lot better
but I did this um study of 200 of these
women's groups in in Kenya in one of the
two months that I was there and what I
saw was
a pretty terrifying cycle where the
philanthropists or the aid organization
would give money to a women's group they
immediately would give it 10 Kickback to
the local
District officer because the money had
to go through him
then they had no skills to cooperatively
cooperatively run their chicken farm or
whatever they were given the money for
usually decided by some
government official or Foreigner
um the whole thing would fail but
whenever the dignitaries would come to
see how the project was doing the women
would parade outside projects they'd put
a show on they would go by fantas
sometimes they would and biscuits
sometimes they would kill a goat and
after looking at these 200 groups I
could only conclude that the majority of
them were spending money
to keep this whole farce alive and um
I remember staying up all night one
night writing the report
and the the first line was good
intentions lead the path to Hell another
famous saying of my mother
um
and I just felt such rage
that there was a machine
that ultimately
was a big lie
that if we really cared about enabling
people to solve problems this is not the
machine we would be doing yeah and on
top of that
the you know as generous as the spirit
is that's that's donating all of these
things it doesn't respect the dignity
piece because nobody wants to be just a
charity case right like this is another
kind of facet of of the things that you
talk about in the book which is finding
a way to inspire that that dignity and
that comes with this model and this
approach where
um these people aren't on the receiving
end of Charity they become stakeholders
and invested so you're aligning the
incentives right A lot of these problems
you're talking about there's a
misalignment of incentives that butts up
against a lack of accountability that
creates like all of these problems and
Acumen is really a reimagination of the
model
that is this hybrid between
philanthropy and you know proper
Investment Banking or venture capital
to get those incentives
um in parallel with the best interest of
solving the problem and getting people
really engaged themselves the people who
are on the receiving end of it
is
like I don't know I don't feel like I
articulated that very well at all it's
beautiful you articulated it beautifully
because yeah what I learned more than
anything else and certainly after the
Rwandan genocide
but in story after Story like this
is that
many well-intended people see a chance
to give a grant and get people a little
bit more income for their income
generating process project but that
income and wealth
is not the opposite of poverty that the
opposite of poverty truly is dignity
it's that ability to make choice and so
when I started acumen
the whole Focus was on what systems
would you build to enable human dignity
rather than just make sure people get
some income and
um
and it felt very clear to me then
particularly after all of these
experiences that markets have a real
role to play because
there's a distribution and a scaling
that's natural you have self-organizing
mechanisms through the good part of
capitalism
and it's limited it too often leaves out
the poor and in the worst of cases it
exploits the poor
charity has a role but it too often
creates dependency
so what if we took philanthropy and
invested it in those entrepreneurs that
were hell-bent on solving some of the
biggest problems of our dead like
sanitation like education like energy
like agriculture
what if we gave them time to really
understand
the true constraints and the obstacles
that get in Poor People's way and build
Solutions so that at the end of the day
they could send their children to
schools they wanted to send their
children to they could get access to
Good Health Care they could
um
get electricity
although I wasn't thinking about
electricity 20 years ago and um
because what I'd seen over and over was
that the poor actually pay more in these
broken markets than the middle class pay
anyway
it's not like the poor sitting around
waiting for somebody to get them water
it just happens to be dirty and the
water they get access to is often
supplied by what's called mafias
extortionary providers
uh
and so
it seemed to me
that we could
start with recognizing that every human
being wants to solve their own problems
we want to be part of contributing in
one way or another and build those
systems that
at the end of the day not only allow
that kind of flourishing but um
solve all of our problems
to help us better understand the
mechanisms behind microbial Health the
good Dr will bolsowitz a board certified
award-winning gastroenterologist and the
New York Times best-selling author of
fiber fueled came back for another gut
health Deep dive breaking down the
latest science on the microbiome and the
powerful health benefits of being fiber
fuel here is Dr B
you're often one to say that the idea of
the microbiome gets conflated in this
reductive definition of just being about
gut health but really what it is is it's
about metabolic Health right and to the
extent that we can tend to our
microbiome
it will improve our metabolic Health
which of course the downstream
implications are that you know we we
become better and more resistant at
fighting off all of these chronic
ailments that are a result of problems
with our metabolic Health metabolic
health is associated with with
inflammation inflammation comes from the
immune system we describe these things
in their own separate way but they're
not separate you know this is all part
of the Confluence of factors that make
us human beings and they're completely
integrated yeah well we're well into
this podcast and uh we have yet to
Define our terms here so if somebody's
stumbled into this episode and this is
their introduction uh to the microbiome
and and their only kind of Association
is that the microbiome means like
bacteria in our digestive system perhaps
we should take a few minutes to kind of
really Define what we're talking about
in in terms of like what is the
microbiome and
um and why is it important yeah the
microbiome is a community of these
invisible microorganisms and there's
several different varieties that are
there but they're they're there they're
covering every external surface that's a
part of us as humans so like they're
covering our skin
um if if we were to literally look at
our thumb there's as many microbes right
there on our thumb as there are people
in the UK uh they're inside our mouth
inside our nose inside a woman's vagina
but they are most concentrated
inside our intestines specifically our
colon which is the large intestine
in that spot you will find that there
are about 38 trillion microbes and 38
trillion is a pretty ridiculous number
it's hard to know exactly how to like
frame that so let me put this into
perspective there's about 100 billion
stars in the sky
so if we were to take all the stars in
the sky all the stars in our galaxy and
Shrink them down to a ball we would have
to place a hundred galaxies Full of
Stars into your large intestine and even
that actually is only a fraction of our
gut microbiome how did you that's a good
one how did you come up with that I'm a
math nerd it's impossible to wrap your
head around that big of a number yeah it
is impossible it's completely ridiculous
but that's that's a part of who we are
every single one of us has a microbiome
right and when in this conversation that
you and I are having when we talk about
the microbiome typically this is what
we're going to be referring to is the
gut microbiome specifically
so and these microbes they're a part of
human history going all the way back to
the very beginning
there's never been a moment where a
human being did not have a microbiome
whoever that first human was they had a
microbiome and from that point moving
forward to today
three plus million years of human
evolution
it was never exclusively human evolution
it was always co-evolution we were
rising and falling with these microbes
and that process galvanized the
relationship that we have with these
microbes
where we grew like very clearly if you
look at the science we grew through
Evolution to really trust
these microbes because we gave them
tasks that we completely need them to do
the job
for us to be healthy humans so starting
with digestion like digestion is access
to nutrients
if we don't get access to nutrients we
don't live
and we need them we rely on them for the
digestion of many of our Foods
we've talked about our metabolism
our hormones let me also inject uh we
talked about uh our immune system our
metabolism let me also add our hormones
and our mood our brain health our
cognition
the expression of our genetic code
they are powerful
and I'm not even explain the one about
the expression of the genetic code is
that is that in reference to our ability
to express certain genetic dispositions
like if our microbiome is out of kilter
then we're not able to you know
basically function because our genes are
are under expressed that are intended to
perform a certain function or what do
you mean by that if you go back to the
the year it was roughly 2000 2001 and
they were wrapping up the Human Genome
Project and this is Francis Collins who
just recently retired but at the time he
was one of the most preeminent
well-respected scientists at the NIH
and they called uh this was Bill Clinton
was the president and he called a press
conference along with Tony Blair and in
the Rose Garden they have all these
people there to announce that they had
just cracked the genetic code and the
reason that this was such a big deal
from their perspective is that they
sincerely believed that once we cracked
the human genetic code we're going to
basically have the path to curing cancer
or stopping heart disease right and um
they really believed that that would be
the truth and the problem is here we are
and it's more than 20 years later and
clearly that is not the truth has not
worked out the way that they thought
that it was going to work out and that's
because we are not a I think this is
actually empowering we are not a set of
predetermined Health outcomes in a
genetic code
instead our genetic code is more like a
series of switches
and you can turn them on
or you can turn them off
then whether or not you do that is going
to determine what actually happens with
our body but the question is who's
sitting at the switchboard
and flipping the switches and the
appearance is that these are the gut
microbes right they're in control of
basically flipping the switch and
determining whether or not we have
health conditions or we don't next up is
ultra Phenom and force of positivity
Camille Heron a woman with 21 Marathon
victories to her name the 24-hour
distance record and a slew of other
crazy world records as well she's a
woman who is narrowing the gender gap
with astounding Feats of endurance and
she shares her unique training style her
philosophy on life and Sport and the
ways running can be self-transcendent in
our episode and in this powerful clip I
feel like there's no limits on what I
can do like if I set a goal for
something like I'm somebody that doesn't
really limit myself on like I just go
after it I just you know bite down and
go after that goal so it's just a
question of like where you want to place
your attention and I think you even
mentioned the the 3100 yeah uh in Queens
yes which is a wild one that I mean that
is just so that blows my mind I I mean 3
100 miles like around like I think it's
like a half mile yeah block and I mean
how do you stay motivated how do you
find joy you know when it's boring
um and I I think I'm somebody that like
I mean I like to use the energy around
me when I'm in races and and you kind of
have to you have to break it down like
how do you eat an elephant you eat an
elephant one bite at a time and so and
I've learned like when I run races like
I need to I need to you know track the
mileage and I need to break down the how
am I gonna eat the elephant yeah and and
so I mean that's something I think about
in races like you know whether I'm going
100 miles 24 hours 3 100 miles like how
do you break down eating the elephant so
well you're no stranger to running
around in circles so you just you're
running around in a circle the
interesting thing with that one is the
course closes at night so you go to bed
and it becomes like a job for the summer
you just wake up and between eight and
five or whatever eight and eight or
whatever the hours are you just go
around that Loop and try to get as many
miles as you can there's a documentary
about it that my friend Sanjay rawali I
don't know if you've seen it yeah and
it's so interesting the people that
excel in that race are are not the
people like they don't look like Runners
they're like average people with you
know all different kinds of jobs and
it's and it really shows you like oh
this is a this is about mental fortitude
this is about like something more than
athletic capacity this is about like a
connection to something Beyond like
those are the people that seem to you
know Excel yeah yeah and I I feel that I
feel a spiritual connection when I go
for World Records I feel like I'm
tapping into something really special
inside of me and I reach a point where I
like transcend and like it's almost like
my head starts to float off of my body
and I think when and when you do
something like that you really have to
tap into that spiritual energy inside of
you to to keep going and to to complete
it because it's just something that just
like you know it's just like Beyond like
what you think is possible tell me more
about that
I feel like I've always had this ability
uh to tap into this this extra energy
inside of me and and I like I remember
when I set my 50 mile world best back in
2015 I think I have like
um maybe it's like 12 miles to go and I
I joke that it was like that the hand of
God came over me and I literally felt
like my head started to float on my body
and I'm just like a machine those last
12 miles and it was kind of one of those
points where
um I was either gonna get the record or
not get the record and I felt like I
just found some sort of like spiritual
connection where my body just became a
machine and it was kind of like my head
was floating and I felt that like many
more times when I've gone for World
Records I feel like even
um I think about when I did my 12 hour
world record I started to fill that I
feel like I I kind of just went into
this like machine mode and and yeah I
mean it was like it's it's incredible I
just I feel it I feel this energy that I
can tap into when I go for these amazing
things so like this Advanced Flow State
where you become this channel for
something else yeah yeah I feel I feel
it like it's incredible I just like even
even racing Harvey I mean it's like I
just I just transcended like this last
couple miles and and I don't know how to
describe it like I just it's like I
almost like detach a bit from uh from my
body and from the pain I'm feeling and I
just become this machine yeah yeah yeah
that's wild well it is that's why you
have to do the 3100 it is this
self-transcendent yeah run that's what
it's called right yeah absolutely I I
feel like like that's gonna be like my
finale as a runner
um how do you think about yourself as a
as a role model obviously you're
inspiring to to everybody but
particularly to
to women women athletes young girls I'm
sure you have opportunities to speak
with younger people like how do you
think about how you carry yourself and
what that means for the next generation
of young athletes yeah well when I when
I'm out there and I'm going I'm about to
do something I mean I think about that
not only the people that inspire me to
to do a race I feel like every race that
I do I have somebody that is inspiring
me and that I think about like
especially later in the race but I also
know that people are watching me and
that I'm bringing inspiration to other
people and I feel that I feel that
during the race I feel like you know I'm
doing this for the world I'm doing this
to you know Elevate the sport to raise
the bar and what women think is possible
and uh like it's such a powerful thing
when you're out there I feel like I'm
it's not just me trying to reach a
personal goal I'm doing this for the
sport I'm creating history and and it
just like totally like elevate hates me
like later in the race just thinking
about that and now being 40 you're not
just breaking barriers in distance and
time you're breaking barriers in age
like you haven't even begun to you know
tap into what you're capable of I'm sure
you've got a whole slew of World Records
you know coming but it it's really cool
because it creates this conversation
around what we're capable of and what
our limits are as we age and as you
redefine it
you're in equal parts inspiring young
people as you are to like the older
people who are who are trying to you
know rethink what they're capable of as
we get older yeah absolutely and I mean
I I think about when I reach my mid-30s
I thought I was on some sort of like
down
to a lot of like marathoners and and you
know Ultra athletes think that they
think that oh you know it's all downhill
from here but I feel like I'm reaching
my Prime right now and I mean it's
incredible because here I've been a I've
been a runner for 27 years and I'm still
getting better and you know at age 40
and uh you know I feel like I'm kind of
dialing in more like I talked about my
diet and my recovery I'm kind of dialing
in more on those factors that you know
maybe I just kind of let them slide in
the past and it wasn't really as dialed
in on them so I'm kind of showing like
you know if I I'm using like more of my
brain and having more wisdom and with my
training and my recovery my diet all
these things and I it's it's like
working yeah yeah yeah how do you
reconcile two seemingly opposite
passions well Elite Ultra marathoner and
full-time High School teacher Harvey
Lewis helped answer this question Andy
gave us a powerful lesson on mindset on
consistency and how to push beyond the
limits of what you perceive possible
here's a clip from episode 658
yeah it's it's wild uh during the race I
actually you know I went through a low
part around like mile I think about 140
or 170 rather and uh it's incredible
because uh I mean I was ha I had like
the
the uh battle inside my mind like the
side that was not one to submit at all
but I had like a little bit creeping in
I thought of like well it would be nice
to like you know just go relax in the
hotel and they'll put my feet up and
like how long has this thing going to go
for so and you're only halfway in and I
didn't know you don't know that's the
thing you don't know how long it's going
to go I had no idea at that time and so
to get through that dark place I like
share with my crew chief and I mean
having a strong crew chief is really
important in this race and I just like
when I got back to a tent I made sure no
one else was nearby I just sat real
quietly to Judd I said hey I'm
struggling through this a bit right now
and uh he came up with a good idea he's
like just visualize that you're running
back and forth to work because I I run
used to work yeah and so like that was
incredible because at that point I was
really able to just go beyond it and
then just focus on each Loop and just
imagine I was running back and forth to
work it was so easy at that point which
is kind of about the same distance right
yeah it's about the same distance so
it's incredible how just changing your
mindset in like can make such an impact
and that really didn't go through any
other
I mean I went through it was tough and
then in the fourth day but I didn't go
through a point that was like as
mentally like where I was in a dark
place like that yeah so you're at Mile
300
of Biggs like I gotta hear about this
like hallucinatory Nirvana moment that
you had yeah so the
this year I would just say like uh it
was kind of crazy because you know you
go through these lows and Highs but
going into 300 it just felt like we were
Invincible almost like in uh more and
more the Japanese Runner he just was
fired up we were both fired up so once
we got past 300 we started doing crazy
things and like uh some of it was like
strategic on my part trying to like wear
him down a little bit
um but some of it was just like
impassioned like just feeling like fired
up and like let's just go so we started
doing things that you probably shouldn't
do after 300 miles like we started
running up the hill like that we've been
walking up since day one and then we
started sprinting through the camp like
again everyone fired up like just kind
of ridiculous things and sometimes we
just like start running super fast
through the woods in places we probably
shouldn't where you'd like crashed so uh
it was and we just sometimes we'd be
hollering like we just start yelling
like not not in like aggressive way
towards each other but just because we
were fired up yeah and like excited
about it like so it's it was wild uh to
hit that that Mark and then feel all
kinds of new energy like I mean I felt
in sometimes more energy that throughout
the whole race I like Loop two right
yeah just going into some crazy gear
that you didn't even know that you had
not even though that you had like that
was what was so special about it because
you you get Beyond 300 miles and then
you realize wow there's these like like
you have more Force than you ever had
even in the first day you're like where
did this come from yeah like where does
it come from I mean what do you make of
that yeah yeah it's it's so much in the
head like because with your training
which will catapult you to that level
like that depends on your mind as well
so I mean so much is the mindset to get
out there when it's cold and rainy and
11 p.m you know like what what's driving
you so then it gets us back to the
question of why and that's the other
major thing and like to be honest with
you whenever I'm doing an a-race that I
really care about I actually write down
my why statement and I write down a
bunch of stuff under why what was the
why I had about 15 things yeah yeah but
uh some are sort of personal
um some definitely would be like uh for
other people like uh you know for my
students or my my parents
uh for
I would like to to impact other people
and their lifestyle and like their their
health and like what they're doing so
like that motivates me a lot to to to do
my very best
to hopefully you know impact someone
else
former corporate lawyer turned New York
Times best-selling author of quiet and
Bittersweet Susan Kane joined me back on
episode 699 to get philosophical on
introversion on bitter sweetness on
Grief creativity connection
spirituality and so much more enjoy this
slice of that exchange
there are babies who are born
um into this world and from the day
they're born you can test their nervous
systems and see that they're more
reactive to all different kinds of
stimulation like they'll they'll
salivate more if you give them sugar
water put it in their mouths and so the
babies who salivate more when they're
two years old and you put them into a
play group of kids they've never met
before those are the babies who are
going to tense up and
and take longer to integrate into the
group because they basically have a
nervous system that is just reacting
more to new inputs and it makes you want
to like slow things down and pause and
check it all out before you're ready
is that like when I think about that the
the word that comes to mind is
sensitivity right which is applicable to
to Bitter sweetness too like I took the
I took your quiz yeah I scored a 7.3 so
I guess I'm I prone to some level of
bittersweetness but I've always thought
of myself as maybe just a little bit
more sensitive than certain other people
and sensitivity could be a word that you
could apply to introversion as well like
they're just more sensitized to their
environment or I mean how do you like is
that a completely different way of
thinking about this or how does that no
it's more like these are all really
overlapping categories they don't lay
totally on top of each other but they
overlap so with bitter sweetness
um which by the way I Define as a kind
of
a state of mind where you're very
attuned to
the way in which joy and sorrow in this
world are forever paired you know you
don't get one without the other in this
life
um and the way in which everyone and
everything we love will not be here
forever but that somehow what comes with
that knowledge there comes a kind of
deep Joy at the beauty of the world so
it's a it's a like a real blend of all
these
um deep instincts
this idea of of of of bitter sweetness
um
I think most people think of it as an
experience but you talk about it as like
a state of being so distinguish those
two things and how you arrived at that
point of view yeah so I mean it is an
experience in the sense of you know like
the moment where you're walking your
child down the aisle or something
that is a quintessential Bittersweet
experience but there's also a view of
the world and a way of being in the
world that's quite Bittersweet
um you could call it melancholic except
that word in our culture is associated
with clinical depression and that's not
really what it means or or it's not the
way I'm using it
um
so the Bittersweet state of being is
much more about like this sense of
it it's a sense of that awareness of joy
and sorrow and of fragility
um Aristotle two thousand years ago
asked the question of what he has this
question of what why is it that so many
of our great poets philosophers and
politicians all have a melancholic
temperament like what is that
so it's something about being attuned to
the gap between the world
as it is and the world as we would wish
it to be you know there's like
it's like the emotional DNA of humans is
like we come into this world with a
sense that there is more perfect and
beautiful world that's out there
somewhere to which we belong but we
somehow find ourselves here instead
right so it's not it's it's this the
yearning and the long the longing like
the idea that things could be better
it's not a despairing per se but it's a
it's a sense that like we're in a
certain place it could be better and and
the melancholic impulse is built out of
like how to get from one to the other
yeah and it's like it's the heart of our
creative impulse you know it's like a
Feeling
of like how do you get closer to that
perfect and beautiful world
for which you were yearning if you look
at the the musicians the great poets the
writers all of the you know painters the
ones that seem to resonate the most are
the ones who are have the facility to
the capacity to kind of take these
seemingly conflicting emotional states
or the polarities of them and weave them
in some way that make sense to us as
humans but perhaps transcends our
ability to like articulate and I think
when you see it it's sort of like when
you hear it you know it when you see it
you know it you're not sure why like why
is it that the the minor key or these
certain songs and the way that they're
constructed
um cultivate that in ourselves I don't
know if there's neurochemistry on that
or any science on that but it really is
like I know what that is I don't know
why I know what that is it makes me feel
a certain way that is you know perhaps
you know seemingly off my optimal State
and yet there's a comfort like you talk
about rainy days and things like that
like you kind of want to languish in it
yeah there's a comfort and there's a
there's a Transcendence in it he was
Leonard Cohen the very first artistic
act that he took was when he was nine
years old and his father died
and um
and he he took one of his father's bow
ties and he wrote a poem and he buried
the bow tie and the poem in the garden
in the backyard garden of their family
house and that was his first artistic
act and it was like he was kind of
repeating that act again and again
throughout his career there's a kind of
like
taking something painful and then
turning it into something else and I
think that's like the real
in terms of how to live that's the real
insight that this whole this tradition
gives us because
it's kind of saying to us
these moments are going to come these
pains are going to come
you have two choices of what to do with
them you know you can suppress it in
some way and inevitably you're going to
take it out on yourself in the form of
depression or addiction or whatever it
is or you're going to take it out on
someone else abuse passive aggression or
you can take those pains and sit with
them somehow
and then
make meaning out of them and transform
them and that's something that we do so
naturally
next up is my friend the brilliant Simon
Hill Simon is a nutrition science expert
he's also an author an entrepreneur a
restaurateur and fellow podcaster over
at the proof which if this clip speaks
to you is a podcast I'm certain you will
love
Simon is a fountain of practical
knowledge that can benefit those
contemplating a plant-based diet as well
as the more seasoned plant-based
Advocates here is Simon Hill
a common fear that a lot of people have
when considering a plant-based diet is
is calcium oh my goodness if I don't eat
dairy I'm not drinking milk my bones are
going to turn brittle where am I going
to get my calcium my understanding is
that dark leafy greens are a pretty good
source of calcium I've never had an
issue with this but how do you think
about that and ensuring that people are
meeting their calcium needs
firstly I would say that building strong
bones is a team game we've reduced it
very much to just calcium but it's so
much more than that and even before
talking about nutrition I think it's
worth emphasizing that exercise is
arguably far far more important both
impact exercise so we're talking about
jogging or skipping uh you know going up
and down stairs or hopping that sort of
impact exercise is a stimulus you know
the the body uh structure reflects
function yeah and and so it responds to
that by laying down more a bone
increasing your your bone mineral
density and then the second type of
exercise resistance training so be it
lower body things like squats or upper
body with bands uh the research is
pretty pretty clear that we need to be
doing this stuff regularly for as long
as possible to prevent a significant
amount of bone loss which does not
actually occur as you age but you want
to slow that down yeah
well dude we did three hours I know we
had to do three hours again because we
did three hours last time
um before we completely shut it down
like any any final thoughts or or
parting words for people I feel like we
covered a lot here I think we gave
people a lot of stuff to think about
yeah
I I think uh you know in the first in
our first conversation we kind of
established the the science underpinning
a plant predominant to exclusive diet
being best for human health and
uh my entire thesis is
uh and I want to kind of make this clear
because I'm not sure I really spoke to
that is that
when you broaden the lens open up the
aperture and and consider how our food
choices affect the planet and you
consider uh what we're doing to billions
and billions of of animals and the
unnecessary pain and suffering that they
are ensuring experiencing and that none
of us would would likely swap places
with them when you do that it does
create a compelling case for adopting a
diet that is as plant exclusive as
possible
and I say as plans exclusive as possible
rather than a sort of firm endpoint
because we all have our own
circumstances means social circumstances
and I'm aware that this will look
different for each individual so uh my
message is is about you know I have
unconditional love for everyone no
matter where they end up
and it's not about perfection this is
about adopting this imperfectly just
like my diet is not perfect it's
imperfect and we
rather than having a few people around
the world
make improvements
perfectly
if we want to see great changes in
public health if we want to see great
changes in planetary Health if we want
to minimize the unnecessary pain and
suffering that we're inflicting then we
need billions of people doing this
imperfectly
so with that in mind my message is to
let go of the Perfection and take some
pressure off yourself takes a remove
that's the self-judgment and just get
started and that may be a small change
you know such as just changing one
component of your meal swapping red meat
for lentils but by getting started
hopefully today or tomorrow you you
start the momentum
uh and you know I have full confidence
in everyone that as they get started and
start to make these changes they will
begin to feel better themselves and that
is hugely motivating
as is
what you feel from a mental point of
view and you know I have made this
transition and I was aware of the health
benefits that were up for grabs but what
I was not aware of was
how good it feels to live more
congruently and to align your actions
with your values and beliefs and the
peace that that that brings so
uh
start slowly take some pressure off and
I wish you all the best of luck next up
is someone I think it's fair to say is a
person near and dear to me she is my
Confidant she is my in-house spiritual
Guru she is my partner in life and all
things her name is Julie Piet AKA
srimati and in this excerpt from episode
710 she shares actionable ways to live
with Integrity to amplify your awareness
and elevate your Consciousness as we
emerge from the pandemic and the
multitude of experiences that that
period rot I think as we emerge out of
this period a lot of people have been
engaged in a deep
self-reflection about how they've spent
their time and how they want to spend
their time going forward right it was
this uh you know moment of forced Repose
where because everyone was home all of a
sudden and we were kind of compelled to
look in the mirror in a way that we
generally don't because we're busy uh I
think a lot of people took stock of like
why have I been you know in this job or
doing this thing and I've seen a lot of
people make huge changes in their lives
but now as the world has started to open
back up it's like oh recession inflation
political division like there's a lot of
noise out there that is fear inducing
and there's good reason for that and you
know chances are we are going into some
kind of economic
um challenges at the moment that I think
you know promotes a restriction of
whatever
uh sense of expansion might be
percolating up in people so maybe it
would be good to talk a little bit about
how to navigate that and if you are
feeling that sense of expansion or
change or an Impulse to more deeply
explore what might be authentic to you
and how to
nurture that and bring it to life and be
more fully expressed and more authentic
and how you're pursuing your life like
what are some
strategies or practices or tools that
you could impart to that person yeah
beautiful well I mean the heart will
never fail you
and that's been my experience
so it doesn't mean that you're going to
have the trajectory that you think that
you're going to have in your mind or in
you know whatever you whatever you
thought your life was going to be but I
would say that this podcast is living
living proof and our journey
the heart will not
leave you it will it will not this is
this is a manifestation of
a heart-centered impulse like I didn't
whiteboard like oh I'm going to have
this podcast and it's going to be this
thing there's nothing about this that
was predictable in any way shape or form
it was
the result of Letting Go more than
self-will like was like well what could
the what what are the possibilities like
and trying different things and not
holding on to anything too tightly and
really just following my curiosity and
what inspired me and
more deeply connecting with my intuition
and my sense of who I wanted to be in
the in the world in in a very
non-defined kind of ephemeral way but
learning to tune into that and to listen
to that
and pay attention to that and take
action on you know those impulses is
what created this it's not because I sat
down and had a goal and said this is
what I'm doing
was the antithesis of all of that yes it
was all of that and you're the one who's
always reminding reminding me of that
when I start to get you know too uh you
know up in my head about stuff
yeah well I mean it was an entire uh
spiritual ritual that actually activated
this entire timeline and it was based on
no sensibility whatsoever except my
unwavering extreme faith that our heart
would not let us down and I knew that I
had to support you to live and
experience your heart's deepest desires
and so we were making decisions that
made no intellectual sense whatsoever
so again the key is inside the heart and
it's in each one of us because if we can
activate what that natural expression is
that is so beautiful So Divine so
profound and it might not be seen by
anyone it's not about being famous or
having like a big reach it's about doing
what is authentic and reminding
ourselves that art creating art and
music and dance with sacred intention is
the greatest gift we can give humanity
and instead we've been reversed to think
that you're you can only be an artist if
you're in a certain circle or if your
art sells for a certain amount of money
or if you're you know one of the greats
that's not true because art is a is a
language and a communication and poetry
and music that is invisible to anti-life
forces it actually gets through it makes
a connection
so the the biggest thing we have to do
is live in resonance with our heart and
it comes back to that question how do
you want to evolve and what are you
hiding
what are we still hiding from ourselves
and if we can refine that through many
different ways I will always go back to
yoga oh bless the yogis of our of our
you know civilization of many many eons
of time I mean The Yoga practices
literally are Shelter From The Storm
they are breathing practices many people
are doing them in a modern way and they
have breathing workshops those are all
Yogi techniques so yoga practice yoga
breathing
um you know this is what cultivates the
presence the awareness of the one that
is breathing us and in the end we only
have our consciousness
you have your Consciousness no one can
ever take that from you and we aren't in
control of a lot of the other things
that happen so it's like my prayer is
for the people in Pakistan in these
extreme floods that when they transition
that the suffering is short
so short
that their creator that their loved ones
at their guides are there to catch them
and that they've transitioned
you know I don't want anyone to suffer
that that is not
um
you know it's not even reconcilable like
how we would choose these human lives to
come in here to face so much of what we
face and you know we're in a very
privileged you know life of course
um but you know life will visit you
wherever you are if you have money it
will come in the form of disease you
know if you it'll come in the form of
divorce it will come to remind you who
you are
coach author and world renowned expert
on all things high performance Steve
Magnus dropped by the studio for his
third but for solo appearance on the
show sharing a new approach to unlocking
true toughness and physical and mental
resilience and how to best lead others
to Optimal Performance
anytime our brain is kind of caught off
guard
we tend to have a threat response
because your brain wants you to survive
right anytime we're like prepared and
it's kind of within our reach we have a
challenge response which is more kind of
testosterone adrenaline driven instead
of cortisol threat driven so when we
look at when we think of like toughness
we often think of like oh just fake it
like put on a mask and you'll be good
but once that's exposed like your
brain's going to jump to that freakout
moment where it's like oh crap sound
alarm like get out of here Escape flight
don't take things on because like we're
not capable right so an example would be
in an Iron Man when somebody's leading
on the bike and they get a flat right
and then they they're all pissed off and
they're throwing their bike and throwing
a tantrum and they look they look tough
because they're doing that but actually
that's weakness because they haven't
prepared for that variable and when it
occurred the stress reaction was to just
like lose your mind or you know in a
tennis match and you're throwing chairs
because of a bad call or something like
that yeah and that's how most of these
things happen is like from the from the
external side it might look tough or it
might look like you care right and like
oh look how pissed off he is like he
cares about his performance but to me
like it's the opposite it's like
well you're just kind of sabotaging
yourself you're not prepared for the
moment you're not figuring your way
through this this stuff and I I think
you can almost summarize the biology or
the Neuroscience of toughness down to
like we talked earlier about can you
keep your mind steady no matter what
kind of chaos is going on around you can
you keep your mind from defaulting
towards that free at freak out reactive
state
or can you keep you know yourself
online rational ability to work through
things
and In the Heat of the Moment the
competitiveness the competitiveness like
often what happens is we default to that
freak out because it's like
almost overwhelming it's this like
emotional charge behind it
and embracing reality is you know that's
a that's a piece here there's so many
other things that you have to practice
in order to maintain your level of
composure under that kind of stress
um
but a lot of it
in my mind has to do with this
distinction that you alluded to which is
the the difference between kind of
bravado false bravado versus real
confidence which is which is earned and
experience based it confidence needs
evidence
you know it that's how you feed it
and in my generation I think we really
screwed this up because we had this huge
self-esteem movement yeah and I remember
Elementary School junior high it's like
you know you just get told you're great
but what the science actually shows is
this is that you know we don't get that
like testosterone bump of like
confidence
unless we've done something to earn it
what a shocking thing to say how dare
you you're gonna get canceled for that
statement Steve you know that right
probably probably
but but I I I think this is like it's
it's so Central to things because like
we get told the wrong idea so much and
instead like we need to do the work and
it's not that you have a certainty about
it but it's to know that hey I've
prepared like I've put in the work I've
been consistent like my brain knows that
I'm at least maybe not going to fall
apart if I enter the arena right you
know I always like to put it as does the
thing have the power or are you in
control and so much of toughness is like
do I have some semblance of control over
things
not complete control but some semblance
where I can influence it so if the thing
has all the control if I can't step away
from the Run say hey you know what I'm a
little sick and I've got a race coming
up so it's probably better than I rest
if I can't do that without like that
anxiety coming up right that should
signal it's an issue that I need to be
able to work with to sit with that
discomfort so that the thing doesn't
have the control and instead I'm making
the wise decision and taking the action
yeah and the coach or the mentor or the
leader has to understand how to instill
that in the people that they're working
with right so that's the difference
between
the controlling Bobby Knights out there
who strip their athletes of any agency
or control versus the empowering coach
who understands how to how to kind of
seed that intrinsic motivation and that
true confidence where they're the
athlete or the mentee is empowered to
make their own decisions and feels like
they have input into the trajectory of
their career the easiest way to make an
athlete worse is to take away autonomy
what does a celebrity Mentalist have to
teach us about high performance mindset
well the answer is more than you would
imagine meet world-class Mentalist and
highly accomplished Ultra Runner owes
Pearlman who joined me back on episode
673 sharing strategies for cultivating
greater confidence endurance and
resilience well why don't you you know
Kick It Off by just explaining what
mentalism is so we're all clear on kind
of the playing field and in which you
operate I think it gets sort of
conflated with with magic and mind
reading and tarot card reading and all
kinds of other stuff so lay the
groundwork on what it is that you do so
it's interesting because I would never
believed if you would have told me I was
going to be a mentalist this is not like
the career path I thought I was going to
be on which is shocking to this day it's
kind of like magic of the mind so
everybody can visualize a magician
because you think somebody picks a card
and they're going to find it with fast
hands right that's kind of the Dynamics
light of hand so what I do is more
analyzing how people think reverse
engineering their decision making and
some elements of body language reading
psychology and honestly group dynamics
social dynamics knowing how people
behave and studying that for decades and
then knowing how to entertain people
that's the key word It's Entertainment
it's not I'm not psychic I don't pretend
to know the future I know I would have
won the lottery by now Rich between me
and you uh but it's reading people and
making it very entertaining and doing in
such a way that it's not explainable
like the key is it's kind of you watch
Magic and you know somebody did
something fast my hands don't move fast
I just do stuff where I'm very good at
guessing things you're very much an
expert at this though I watched a whole
ton of of your videos I watched all the
America's Got Talent uh performances and
Ellen and the Today Show and all the
story so you have an incredible like
stage presence and command of what
you're doing
um and it's impossible for me as a
layperson to try try to deconstruct what
the cues are that you're kind you know
the sort of foundation that you're
laying and you're so in this flow of
what you're doing but I have to imagine
that you're paying such close attention
to you know what's coming out of the the
person's mouth how you're kind of cueing
them up how you're leading them down a
certain path and if there's something
not going your way you have to kind of
redirect it and and you know land that
plane in the place that you want it
where you want to stick that Landing
right so it seems like you're kind of
reverse engineering all of this like you
know where you want it to end up and you
have to take this person on a journey
that's gonna land them there without
anybody being the wiser very well put
like exactly that think of a movie and
this is the best way to describe it
think of a movie with the director's cut
that you never saw right the director
points the camera at what they want you
to see but there's other elements in the
movie so what I do it's very funny
because it's not linear not to be like
too in the weeds I don't usually just
say hey think of this and I'm going to
guess this I kind of take you on a path
where amazing things happen and you
don't really know exactly what's going
to take place and that's the advantage
for me that's why I'm not working for
the FBI profiling people or like at a
casino there's certain things I do that
give me a tactical advantage in life if
you will but it's also done in the
course of entertainment where I can't
just go into a casino and rack up
winnings I can do certain things but
they know how to neutralize my advantage
but in essence yeah I know how to
observe people I generally know how
you're going to behave and even in the
moment you think I'm going to change my
mind I'm gonna do something different
right now I know you're going to do that
yeah we're going to get into how you
know that and I know you're going to be
cagey about what you're willing to
reveal
um but I'm going to work on trying to
get you to divulge a little bit right
smell the beans so what is the uh the
overlap like between what you do
professionally and how your running kind
of informs that like does it you know
how does it enhance your creativity what
is the practice around that what are the
kind of mindset tools that you developed
that are applicable in both of these
disciplines
I've tried to figure out and it's it's
not like it's hard to articulate some of
it because everybody knows that if they
find something that's a practice like
you just called it whether it's yoga
whether it's you know meditation whether
it's running is your brain gets into a
zone that I think we don't have enough
of nowadays which is you tune out which
you don't you're not thinking of all the
parts of your life that you have to do
and you're not on your phone or
Electronics or things that suck you in
and that's when my biggest creative
bursts happen they happen when I have to
do something like you just said
necessity is the mother of invention
constraints you have to have those
um and also when I'm running I'm just
like that's when I zone out I just my
There's Something About Moving And it's
different for all different people it's
funny because I don't think of running
as something I would enjoy when I see
someone running it doesn't look fun to
me and when I was a runner as in high
school and I hated so much I still am
that person but something about it now
just evens me out it kind of the way my
mind goes into that zone it's made me a
better Mentalist because I go into that
same thing where I can hyper focus in a
way and it's kind of like visualizing a
race before I'm ever at a race I've
already run that race a hundred times in
my head I've already thought through
where it's going and that same kind of
methodical
uh deciphering all the little angles of
it and trying to also while also just
letting yourself go
it's a little bit of both like mentalism
what I do it's an art and a science
and running I think is the same way yeah
I mean I the way I think about it is
you're basically flexing this muscle of
of being comfortable with being
uncomfortable like you're acclimating
yourself to a certain kind of discipline
that just enures you to this idea that
you always have to be like iterating and
creating and pushing forward because the
running you know is always like holding
you to account right so if you carry
that level of discipline into your
professional life like these two things
can feed each other but I do think
there's something you kind of just
briefly mentioned about not getting
ahead of yourself like in ultra running
like you have to be present with that
pain and suffering if if you have such a
long distance to go and you're having a
hard time and you start thinking about
that like you're toast right oh you're
toast you have to be rooted in the
moment and I would imagine not being a
mentalist but thinking like for you to
do what you do on stage like you have to
be so in it in the moment of what you're
doing in order to be able to execute
yeah I ever thought of it that way but
you're absolutely right like I can't I
if I lose track of it it's kind of like
something to say if you don't if you're
thinking about what you're going to do
after you catch the ball you don't catch
the ball and that's a lot of my mess-ups
have been that I'm thinking too far
ahead and I really have to focus on
what's happening at that moment and
running is I know it's a great escape
it's just uh
it's so fun to not know what's going to
happen and and with the Ultras the big
challenge of it is just knowing that
you're going to suffer and and seeing
how you're going to do in the suffering
yeah and the longer it is the more of a
mental thing it is yeah it's all mental
and so and the mental is what you do
right the mental is all I do yeah right
they go hand in hand
good Lord what an incredible Year I hope
you enjoyed this look in the rear view
links to all the full episodes and the
social media accounts for all the guests
excerpted today can be found in the show
notes on the episode page at
richroll.com part two with a bunch more
awesome excerptic convos will be up
later in the week
stay tuned until then be well enjoy the
holidays in gratitude peace
plants
[Music]